now what does this mean what does that
mean right well this is shorthand for
two numbers one of them is minus 2 minus
3 3 minus 2 minus 3 3 and the other one
is minus 2 plus root 3 that's what the
plus or minus means it's shorthand
because you guys know how famously lazy
mathematicians are we prefer to write
that than all of this but that's what it
means
okay okay these are the solutions okay
so now you can see why we had so much
trouble before you remember how we you
remember how we got quite good at
guessing the pair of numbers right
you're like 2 & 3 nailed it
3 and negative 4 nailed it you're never
gonna guess these because they're there
are these square roots in there who
would think of imagining those okay but
it really does work remember we wanted
them to add to this and multiply to this
watch another color here my two answers
down here I'm gonna add them and see
what happens there too hey man thanks
okay so I'm adding this pair of numbers
right
these guys are important if you think
back all the way to when we did surge at
the start of the year I said these this
pair of numbers actually has an
important name they were related in an
important way it starts with a c' is a
long time ago very good these are called
conjugates
okay now conjugates in that chart
klunder gets matchup cuz look CN is a
minus root 3 and a plus root 3 what
happens when you add them together what
happens they they cancel out right so
you get left with this do you see that
which just gives you negative 4 now we
were expecting four right we're
expecting four but the reason why is
we're actually adding up the solutions
not the numbers that go in the fact is
do you see that look what happens if you
add these guys up what do you get you
get negative 5 it's the opposite of this
okay if you multiply them you'd get 6
let's see what happens if we try a space
I do let's see what happens if we
multiply help me out you're gonna have
to help me because when you think of
that pair of numbers when you think of
the pair of numbers 2 & 3 you're not
actually thinking of this solutions
which are these guys you're thinking of
the factors that give you solutions
they're actually opposites do you see
that it's because they're opposites that
you get this being opposite okay however
with this watch it's really really quite
lovely actually watch what happens when
we expand we know how to expand okay
negative 2 times negative 2 negative 2
times root 3
negative root three times they give to
negative root three or positive root
three but look look what happens here in
the middle you see these guys again
Bam Bam oh that's a that's a - sir
they're right these Serbs have canceled
they've canceled well the which leaves
you with right there okay all right so
so so so so so let's tie this all up
okay this method you just learned
completing the square
it's what you use when you cannot
factorize like everyone looked at this
and looked at this and you're like I
don't know I don't know what to do I
can't think of something right you can
complete the square with any quadratic
equation whereas you can only factorize
with some of them I'm just gonna wait
for everyone's attention
still waiting okay
if you haven't already please make sure
you emphasize this part yeah half and
then square because that's the key part
of completing the square I walked you
through this so now I want you to walk
me through this this is the question I
gave you at the beginning you couldn't
solve it before except Leo now you can
okay so help me out have a look what was
the very first thing that I did to both
sides yeah I got rid of this number here
it wasn't helping me wasn't help me
factorized so I subtracted it from both
sides okay but then I did that step
after which this whole process is name I
completed the square by adding something
what did I add you know do this process
right I've got a half and then square so
what's half of this one and a half if
you square that your calculator should
tell you that's two and a quarter okay
so two little quarter I add it to the
left so I better do it on the other side
okay so far so good why did I do that
why do I add this strange awkward number
what did it allow me to do I've now made
a square what is this square now I
didn't tell you much about how I did
this but I wonder if you've worked out
oh I know
I'll give you cool it starts with an X
plus what's this thing here going to be
think about it have a look yeah yeah you
see how I went having in square to get
this number if you want to think about
this number you just have to do the
having that's all you had to do to go
from there to there which in this case
was one and a half
these are icky a number that's why I did
that one what's on the right hand side
when you simplify that number five and
four would do it or 1/4 504 is fine okay
I've made this square now I factorize
that what did I do with that at this
point what do I do
I don't have squares anymore because I
took the square root of both sides so
that leaves me with X plus 1 and 1/2
what have I got on the right-hand side
just be careful remember that weird
thing because it's very good there's two
numbers on the right-hand side plus or
minus the square root of 5 over 4 like
so I'm almost there now have a look what
am I going to do to both sides I'm going
to subtract that from both sides that
gives me this and those are your answers
two of them okay now I know it does look
a bit um they're messy numbers that's
why I mistakenly I should have written
four there it would have come out a bit
neater it's still the answer by the way
you can make this thinner I will point
out what I would probably do is put your
irrational numbers hat on your Serge hat
what five over four when you take the
square root of that we can simplify that
we can write that bed off can anyone see
how I can write that a little bit better
on do you see that before the
denominator is a square do you notice
that it's four right so I can write it
as root 5 on 2 because that's root 4 you
see that all right this is the answer
you're done but if you want it simpler
which we often do you would do this okay
I wrote minus 1 and 1/2 as an improper
fraction so that I could get these guys
together so here's my final answer it's
still a bit messy but that's because
surds are messy okay so there's our
answer